let's move on to our five headlines
[Music]
well these are always fun joe biden
was interviewed by i believe yahoo news
and was asked
whether he would take a cognitive test
uh and his
answer you might say proves why he needs
one watch
have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man
that's like saying you before you got in
this program if you take a test where
you're taking cocaine or not what do you
think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i
know you're trying to goad me but i mean
i'm so
forward looking to have an opportunity
to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
there could be plenty of time
and by the way as i joke with them you
know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental fil
my physical as well as my mental fitness
oh joe
joe jojo that that you know i'm at the
point now where i actually am rooting
for joe during these interviews i really
am i i don't i don't say that ironically
i really want him to get through it and
perform well in the interviews
i don't want him to win the election but
just from the sheer
weight of the of second-hand
embarrassment watching this
i i i i want joe to do well i really am
pulling for him
um though i watching this i'm not really
sure if it's
if dementia is the problem versus
drunkenness
because he really came off like a like a
drunk guy especially in the first part
of that interview come on man
come on man that that would be like me
asking you
if you were taking cocaine
come on man
um it's uh it's
it's bad it's bad news and this is this
is in
here's the difference between joe biden
and donald trump we played that
interview yesterday
uh of of donald trump axios and
it was i mean unless you
have completely sacrificed your brain to
partisanship there's no denying that
that interview was a disaster for donald
trump but
um and he did stammer around around like
he tends to do
it was relatively incoherent but it's
it's not incoherent in exactly the same
way there's sort of a difference
where whatever else you say about donald
trump you don't you don't really get the
impression that he's
plunging into senility even though he's
not much younger than
than joe biden you don't you don't get
that impression for with his uh
incoherence and his eccentricity shall
we say
it's just that's who he is that's how
that's how he's always been that's just
his personality
for better or worse uh with joe biden
though it's a very
different sort of thing as i think
most people can tell if they're being
honest number two this was interesting
kindergarten cop
the movie kindergarten cop is now
canceled
as we go through and belatedly purge all
books shows movies films that uh
might be offensive to anyone anywhere
for any reason kindergarten cop
the movie where arnold schwarzenegger
goes undercover as a kindergarten
teacher
i don't remember why he did what was the
reason for that
was there was it was one of the
kindergarten students was like a
in a drug gang or something he was
trying to i don't remember
um anyway that's now on the chopping
block it was supposed to be shown at a
film festival in portland
and it was pulled after activists
complained about it which really is not
a surprise i mean
it's a film festival in portland
i would already assume that you can't
show any movie in portland
unless it's a movie about a black
transgender polygamist furry
overcoming adversity and learning to
embrace his sexuality
um as far as i know there isn't any such
movie so i guess that's another way of
saying
you can't show any movie in portland
until someone makes that movie
and then that will be the only movie you
can show in portland um
but anyway kindergarten cop got pulled
and get this it's
the reason it got pulled is because it
normalizes
it normalizes the police and it promotes
the idea of having police in school
uh and that's and that's a very terrible
thing apparently we don't want that
i was actually surprised by that because
the moment i saw the headline of
kindergarten cop getting canceled i
assumed they were dumping the movie
because of this scene
boys have a penis girls have a vagina
thanks for the tip what a transphobic
bigot was that kid ever arrested
i hope so probably not though he's
probably still prowling the streets
promoting you know biological science
and thereby
killing people somehow gotta do
something about that
uh but no that was that was not the
reason that
the movie was canceled all the more
reason to castle of course but
i guess no one no one noticed that and
by the way the reason
no one noticed it is because the people
that are outraged by the movie
clearly have never seen it they just all
they heard is the title kindergarten cop
that's all they needed to know number
three jerry falwell jr president of
liberty university raised some eyebrows
as they say
when he apparently posted on his
instagram a photo of himself and a young
lady
on a yacht in revealing outfits
drinking what would very much appear to
be alcohol
here's the picture which was deleted but
not before a reporter for the houston
chronicle grabbed it and put it on
twitter
so there you go there um you've got the
young lady unbuttoned
mid mini shorts that the shirt hiked up
falwell too horrifyingly
has his own pants unbuttoned and his
midriff showing
and and you know now i looking at this
really feel the urge to burn out my eyes
with a soldering iron
like i said these pictures were deleted
um and from what i've read this was on a
yacht
some kind of or some other kind of boat
was was was apparently a costume part
i'm not sure what costume
this is supposed to be and let me also
point out that falwell is 58 years old
and this really only proves my point
that grown men grown adults should not
wear costumes
certainly not that costume but really
any costume
as as a male once you get over the age
of like
10 uh you're too old for costumes and if
you're a grown man
you're especially too old now
you can say that this isn't a huge deal
and it isn't in the grand scheme of
things
but the problem is that he's the
president
of liberty university and liberty has
very strict guidelines and rules and
according to those rules
students can be fined or even expelled
about five times over
for taking that same picture that's the
issue
um he violates multiple rules that
students
can not only can be penalized for but
but
are penalized for have been many times
the alcoholic beverage
uh the outfits students have faced
very harsh penalties for exactly this
kind of thing
and now you can you can say that well
it's different because he's
not a student and he's not on campus
okay fine
all right but it is to put it mildly
extremely poor leadership to go
and do not just do but then publicize
yourself doing
the very thing you punish other people
for doing
and you know i've never been a big jerry
falwell fan
to be honest with you and for this
reason this is why
christian frauds who enrich themselves
um there's just something
about those types that i don't like i
don't know maybe it's just me it just
they rubbed me the wrong way
number four uh there's been a lot of
coverage recently of the q anon
conspiracy
theories and you know followers of q and
just to be clear a follower of
q is someone who's a follower of random
trolls who post
things on message boards claiming to be
operatives in the government
of course no evidence is ever provided
for any of these claims
and no one asks for it they just follow
along anyway
um that doesn't stop you know with the
conspiracy theorists of course that
never stops anyone from latching on
uh but but there's been a lot of
coverage of this recently the media is
trying to gin up
concern about q anon uh and and this is
not to be conspiratorial myself but i
think this is deliberate
the outlet axios which the ones who did
the interview with trump yesterday
they have an article claiming that q
anon is rising
becoming more prominent this is what
they say
among other things they say conspiracy
theories tied to q anon are growing more
popular
there was more than 10 times as much
google
uh search interest and q anon in
mid-july than in mid-january according
to google trends data
q anon pages and groups on facebook had
nearly 10 times more likes at the end of
last month than they did in july
or last july there has been a 190
increase in the daily average number of
tweets with popular q and on hashtags
since march
um and the article claims parts of the
mainstream republican party have latched
on helping drive its conspiracy
conspiracy theories mainstream 11 q anon
supporters are now 2020
republican congressional nominees that i
would have to look up myself before i
would take them at their word on that
one
but either way two points to be made
here
the first as i said i think there's a
deliberate attempt right now by the
media
to make the q anon people more visible
and the obvious reason to do this
is to discredit conservatives and by
extension donald trump
and this is one of the main reasons why
i hate these delusional idiotic
conspiracy theories
um because they make us all look like
morons
even though q anon you're in a tiny
fringe it doesn't matter
it's it's embarrassing to all of us the
second point
you know the question always is like why
do people go in for these kinds of
conspiracies especially one like q
that is so absurdly lacking in any
supporting evidence
whatsoever and i think part of the
reason for that as i've been thinking
about in fact i was reading a book
recently not about q anon but that
mentions this phenomenon called
agent detection and this is a phenomenon
in all sentient creatures where
you know animal or human assume we we
tend to assume
that there's purposeful intention behind
events that may or may not actually have
purposeful intention behind them and
this is this is an evolved capacity and
it's necessary for survival you can see
why so for example a deer in the woods
hears rustling in the leaves and runs
off assuming
that the rustling was caused by a
predator it could have just been the
wind but instinctively the deer assumes
intent
assumes there's an intelligent agent
behind the noise
and runs off which you could see how
that would aid in survival
we do this too we hear a bump in the
night you know at your house
and immediately you assume that there's
an intruder right
even though almost always for almost
everyone
in almost every case the noise has some
innocuous cause but
it's a survival instinct where the first
thing you think is someone's in the
house
so sometimes people can have what's
called hyperactive
agent detection where they're inclined
to find intelligent and purposeful
agency behind every corner
lurking in everything and i think that's
the problem with conspiracy theorists
perfect example i mean you could there
are thousands of examples you could use
but perfect example of this not from q
anon but from a different conspiracy
theory
the grotesque and horrendous sandy hook
conspiracy theory uh the claim that
there was no massacre it was all an act
and
the parents of these murdered children
are lying okay one of the lines of quote
evidence
for this was that an article was
posted after the attack
about the attack but with a time stamp
from before the attack happened the
conspiracy theories with their
hyperactive agent detection jumped in
and presumed that there was some
sinister intention
behind this right some actual willful
reason for it
um now there wasn't time stamps on the
internet are often wrong it's totally
normal there's nothing there's nothing
even very strange about it and besides
what even would be the claim here
that the media was in on the conspiracy
theory and knew that they were going to
do this hoax
and um and then posted an article about
it before they even did it why would
they do that
just it doesn't even even on the
conspiracy theories
theorists theory it doesn't make any
sense at all
but um even so not to mention the whole
idea of having a conspiracy theory that
is that
wide-ranging that includes all these
government agencies and the media
and somehow everybody keeps the secret
no have you ever met
a person they're horrible at keeping
secrets the idea that hundreds of people
in all these different industries could
be involved in something like that
and never tell anybody is uh is just
another reason why the whole thing is
absurd
but in any event that's what asian
detection is conspiracy theorists see
something that's kind of an anomaly
or a coincidence or an unexplained
detail and they in their heads
extrapolate this entire wild story
that is purely an invention of their
imagination but they don't realize it
because it's an instinct and for them
it's an instinct gone
gone completely mad
or in any case that is my theory to
explain their theories
number five from from the bbc german car
maker audi has
apologized for an advert showing a a
little girl eating a banana
in front of a high performance car after
it drew a torrent of criticism on social
media so
i almost feel like i don't have to read
past that that's just all you need to
know
uh they were it's a girl eating a banana
next to a car
and that people were upset i don't even
there's you can see the picture there i
i can't even quite
imagine you have to be pretty creative
speaking of agency detection it'll be
pretty creative to find a way to be it
wouldn't occur to me to be offended by
that
and that's the one thing i respect about
these politically correct
whiners is that the one thing they're
very creative just like the q anon
conspiracy theorists actually
very they're creative as well and i
respect that uh so very creative and
finding it to find something as not
as innocuous as a child next to a car
and you find multiple reasons to be
offended by it
there's something that's that's an
actual skill i don't think it's a it's a
skill that really
will do you much good in life and
certainly it's harmful to society but
it's a skill all the same well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date
on all of our future content